breaking news now thames water says it  will announce a temporary host pipe ban  in the coming weeks so not immediately  we know that we've already seen water  bans in hampshire and in  sussex a thames water spokesman said  given the long-term forecast of dry  weather and another forecast of very hot  temperatures coming this week we're  planning to announce the temporary  u-span in coming weeks we've written to  the environment agency to update them on  our approach  and informed off-what the timing is not  confirmed due to number of operational  and legal procedural requirements but  we'll be updating our customers partners  regulators and stakeholders at the  earliest time to ensure a coordinated  approach  in the meantime terms of water is urging  customers to only use what they need for  essential use